Now that we have seen Pshare and Gshare, let's
do a quiz about them. Let's say that we
have this fragment of C code, where I goes
from 1,000 down to zero. And for odd number
I's, we are going to add the I to N, otherwise we just don't do it. This code
might translate into a similar program like this. This
branch here is the test for exiting this loop,
when r1 is zero. This is testing the
least significant bit of r1. And if that bit
is zero, that means we have an even number, so we jump to the even label. If the
number is odd then we add it to R3
which in this case is representing n. Either way
we decrement the R1, this is the I minus,
minus and we unconditionally branch back to the loop.
And the exit label for exiting the loop is here. If we want to get good
accuracy on all of the branches in this
code, then the history should be how much for
Pshare, write the number here, and for Gshare,
write the number here. So we're just talking about
how many bits of history we need, to
get good prediction accuracy for all of these branches.